okay uh call a Mee to
order so um first step uh let's let's do
the pledge John alers and Pledge of
here United States of
America stands one
nation indivisible with liberty and
justice for all thank
you
so since the uh last meeting the uh we
had formed a subcommittee to look at as
we all know we had money to uh bring in
consultants and uh the original
subcommittee was uh the
chair uh
goo uh Fred Charlie and Aaron but then
joining us that day were Tim Senator
Lang and representative Ames as well so
we had a pretty good group there um
where we talked through the issues and
decided I think on the basic framework
of an RFP that will be going out and
then Charlie thankfully
volunteered to to put put the meat
around the put the meat around the bones
and then all the boiler plate that goes
with a state RFP which most of us don't
know so uh Charlie do you just want to
just talk to it and then since since
Charlie uh got this now everybody
received that in advance you have it in
front of you anyway but um since then
Aaron Aaron got back to us I think Fred
and then
uh the games got back to us with some
thoughts on on this as well so Charlie
sure I'll jump in start um Mr chair the
um was a basic draft of what an RFB
looks like for a gaming consultant um it
was based on the conversations we had at
the subcommittee at our offices um and
it was forwarded to the subcommittee
last Wednesday I believe for comments
and uh input um and soly I'll leave it
there um and happy to take any input
obviously this is a document created for
the for the membership not just us uh
and but it is a state RFP so does have
to comport to State RFP requirements but
it does not in terms of the the guts of
it
the it's open for a discussion and
revisions so okay I think I think Aaron
you were the first to weigh in if you'd
like to just uh make your comments about
see right and I I think the key thing
there is other HHR jurisdictions I mean
there are difference between slot
machines and these historic racing
machines so I think we we do want to
compare apples to apples as best we can
so uh I I I don't have a problem with
expanding it I don't know about anybody
else who else would like to weigh on
that dick just to say just to say that I
concur thank you for picking that
up Fred Fred you had some comments too
that you had shared
exactly it you know it just be repeating
the same we need to compare apples to
apples you know uh we can't compare the
uh the slot machines I'm sure the
operators would love slot machines but
um you know we need to compare what we
have if I
recall the two that was specifically
Virginia
oh there we go uh yeah they're the two
largest I think most comparable in terms
of number of properties and number of
scale just a question see you seem to be
do what about West Virginia what's West
Virginia got West Virginia has full slot
machines and I don't know if they're
technically slot machines or VTS but
they're full gaming okay and and they
operate like 24/7 correct correct
okay so I think they might be a good
somebody for us to look at those are lar
there some very large scale conss I
think thousands of games and and some of
the ones near DC so size may be
different but I think sure I mean I
think the more jurisdictions we compare
it to the better that way it doesn't
allow people to poke holes through it
right sure sure thank you thank you m
yeah I tend to agree with that last
statement
too I mean for a consultant I shouldn't
take them that long to figure out all
these other states they probably already
know the information about uh we should
have as large a sample as we can get oh
yeah sure I mean I gaming across the
country takes all kinds of
forms you know whether it be class two
or you know slot machines and HHR
machines are both class three they just
are and so you shouldn't limit it to
just HHR machines you should see what
the if we're worried about saturation
you should see what other jurisdictions
have for saturation
as well as what the revenue is per
jurisdiction per device it shouldn't be
limited by state it should be limited by
revenues being drawn from the populace
around it so I would in the interest of
opening it up I think I can redraft it
so that it's comparable jurisdictions or
comparable gaming jurisdictions because
there are
401 gaming jurisdictions something like
that so they would have this data at
hand so I can open it up liter just not
limit it to two other states but but
also but but do emphasize
that let's make sure we have enough uh
historic racing yeah no question
yeah hisor racing in Arkansas this hisor
racing in
Wyoming I know I'm missing
one uh those are the big ones but
certainly V I think Virginia and
Kentucky have a similar model of number
of I think and I think Senator delandro
brings up a great Point too whether it's
calculated into what comes back from
from these reports hours of operation
there there's a difference there
definitive difference and how do they
calculate that into a 24hour day
operation compared to the model we have
so there's a component there I'm sure
that's going to have to play in right so
the RFB process we're going to bring
bring these um unclone vendors
in uh before us uh to describe what
they're going to do or what they're
proposing to do yeah we may we may
narrow that down a little B beforehand
but we we'll see who kind of meets the
criteria if I could propose a schedule
because time is the essence rfps take a
while we have to get GNC approval um
because it is a state contract so I
would propose that I'll take a redraft
based on this conversation send it out
today's Monday you should get it by
Wednesday and then if there's no
objection we'll go with it and I'll
we'll release it next
Monday um there's a time there's a
schedule in the RFP draft itself in the
document
so so on page
two release the
15th we'll advertise it we'll send it to
at least the the shops that I know and
Aaron if you could send me a list of
anybody you you think I should in terms
of companies and I know spectrum is an
obvious one and and you mentioned
Innovation there's a couple others I
know
but
yeah and so Mr chairman if you want to
appoint an RFP committee versus the
group as an RFP sort of questions and
answers and the like or you rather do it
as as the committee of the whole oh as
as we get questions from the vendors
yeah I don't think the whole I think it
should be limited maybe you and I
okay we'll get a lot of tech we as if
you've done our fees before I've done
thousands you'll get a lot of questions
that are just pointless to send to all
of you like you know what what font does
the response have to be in Garand or
Times New Roman you know so I would
suggest just a couple of people
if well send yeah I don't want to take
it over I have a day job so
right um does anybody else would like to
be on that what are you calling
RFP uh committee thick and naron all
right want we why we just go and Fred so
that that all of us as the questions
come at I we can we can coordinate via
phone or
whatever the the questions how we want
to answer those questions and then we'll
get back to these if I could offer um
Kelly work with with us as well yes so
that she can be the central repository
for all the questions and answers and
the like all right and so on the RFP
itself it'll list her as the individual
to contact okay through me through our
office okay yeah that that'll be a good
fun let through
there
yeah yes um before we leave this subject
I had sent out last night sorry it was
so late um also with the wrong email
heading but uh I managed to get it out
um some additional language for the RFP
as a suggestion and Charlie I hope you
got that maybe you didn't no I'm just
sorry I right the meetings this morning
all right um I got some I made some
copies I don't know whether there's
why yeah that's is fine the uh
but you see in uh huge black
letters um at the bottom and then over
the next is is what I'm suggesting this
isn't a big deal by the way it's
just I in section two of the RFP there's
a description of charal gaming and it's
basic basically the games and um and I
thought since we're asking the uh
respondents to this RFP to give us a a
proposal um related to charitable gaming
that we needed to flesh this out and
reference the regulatory structure the
fact that these games can uh uh live and
Thrive hopefully in the same setting as
other
games um and um that we do have some
Provisions related to responsible gaming
including a
Council um and just flag that so that
the respondents will respond to
the the context that we live in get the
idea and and Charlie you can do a better
job than I can so feel free
to
obviously yes and the other thing that
dick uh did send to us is
uh you s everybody I I forward that to
all members of the commission this is Ed
talber who's uh one the co-director of
the Council on on what on responsible
gaming um and uh he wrote a letter about
uh self-exclusion
uh and the process which he he's and
others have found frustrating um and uh
wanted to flag that issue for the
commission uh he it's a letter to the
commission members it's not a letter to
me but he's dealt with me before so uh
he found it easier to send it to me and
asked me to forward it so that's what
you got there uh just being forwarded by
me and it's a very interesting letter by
the way about sort of the uh the
Grassroots issues that arise around uh
responsible gaming this is again in as
side this is nothing to do with the P
but uh without objection I think we'll
we'll invite the council in one of our
meetings to discuss this yeah that would
be
great i' I've I've noticed uh it maybe
some of my colleagues have noticed that
now responsible gaming and how you do it
is now part of the the message that's
coming across with the ads I don't bet
too much be careful to do this do this
do this to this bag bag bag bag you know
points that are noted uh by let's call
responsible
individuals I think it's it's important
it seems to be that's coming all all of
a
sudden there's a re there's a reason why
that's coming and uh I I I I think with
the tremendous expansion of activity and
how you do it uh there are problems that
uh come along with that and we all we
all have to face that that's all I yeah
I think that the the industry the
industry understands that and is looking
for a way to deal with it right think
within our scope of what we're going to
do we're going to be addressing this and
I think this is they they
volunteered their thoughts I think we
should invite them in to discuss it
further so that'll be great uh what I
neglected to do was uh to mention that
um uh attorney general from all hasn't
been able to make our meetings and U
he's uh agreed to have a substitute
which we allow we do allow
substitutes uh to come before us and
this is Mark
theofano that it right you got it right
there you go okay Mark Mark turns to do
turns out he does a lot of work with
with the lottery uh so so he knows the
topic
sorry I'm sorry I didn't do that before
before we started can you give your name
again sure it's a deloro d l l
apostrophe o r f a n
o and I'm an assistant attorney general
department Justice yeah good it Amer I
was going to say I was going to
say well you know we got to balance a
sheet
got so all right I wanted to keep the
number the same uh given the fact that
General attend good all right so uh I
think we're going to move forward as we
discussed that uh Charlie take another
crack at this with the input that we got
from the members uh it sounds like we're
all agreeing with the changes that were
being
proposed uh and then uh you'll send it
out to the
members and then we'll do a quick a it's
got to be a quick response if you have
any other comments respond on that day
you get it please uh when you think it's
going to go on Wednesday or something
like that because we we want to get this
RFP out and wheels Mo in motion on this
one uh so that we have enough time for
them to do their work that the
Consultants do their work and then for
us to uh digest hear what they have to
say and formulate any recommendations
that we need to down the
road GNC yes get on the calendar for the
governor and Council for
right uh yeah explain how that works
again I think it's going to be you and I
right uh likely yeah you and I uh we'll
go up and um it's submitted through
Department of adment Services there's a
calendar which you have to get below be
in front of a certain date to on the
regular calendar I would suggest not
being on the sort of emergency calendar
the council doesn't like that they just
don't they like would they want to have
a time to think about it read it um they
may have questions about it so in the
past this RFP has been proposed to them
and we've had questions from the
counselors which I imagine we'll have as
well so so this is the the RFP itself or
who we decide to select it's the who we
select and the request to contract with
that person has to be approved by the
executive Council okay so that that
would be the back end of the RFP process
correct there would be the last step
before they're engaged right right
they're usually it's a very small subset
of the group goes um
usually sort of in past it's been the
three people in this side of it's the
AG's office the head of the lottery and
chair of the committee okay all right so
but that's your call to sort of if you
want to appoint folks to go there's no
magic to it it's just that's how it's
worked because I have to go because it's
out of our budget right so so if they
decide to have a meeting in Coos County
that
day if you to go to p
I know they make I know they take the
road the show on the road so ums that's
why I want to get this our meeting oh
right all right so that's the RFP I
think we're all set
there um since our last
meeting uh the
house uh Ways and Means Committee voted
out an amendment to Senate Bill
112 and I thought it important that we
understand what was in Senate Bill 112
and U Fred set on our commission here
was the Prime sponsor of that Amendment
so Fred I I ask Fred to just kind of
walk through what that that Amendment
will sure and thank you Mr chairman just
keeping to the the two major points
because there is some housekeeping stuff
relative to employee residency and other
things what what it comes down to is uh
um the HHR machines and Licensing them
um the moratorium language that we've
all talked about we don't necessarily
all agree on but we can agree that this
the formation of this commission doesn't
negate us going forward as far as uh
pushing legislation it um what I did
with this was allow for the present
operators who have applied for is or who
are in the process of uh securing HHR in
their charitable Gaming facilities and
also anyone else in the queue that may
have an application in with Lottery at
present uh up until October 18th of this
past year so that window uh is closed on
the 18th from what uh director McIntyre
has told me there's five applications in
the queue so that would bring us up up
to about 19 operators with the ability
for
HHR um also uh another major component
that we've discussed at this commission
is the component of rent to the
Charities and this basically in a
nutshell eliminates the ability of any
of these operators to collect rent from
stop okay so um so let's go back to the
first item
so what your bill does it says Uh
there's a is this a temporary
moratorium um as it's written no it's a
permanent
moratorium um and we all know that one
legislature does not bind the hands of
another but it's my my belief and the
people that I represent in Salem who
believe that that this needs to be hard
stopped at this point because of uh
saturation and and and uh what the
possibility of the future in relation to
this particular game may or may not be
well this certainly is topic that this
commission is going to be addressing
anyway I mean you you you you moved
forward with a bill still hasn't passed
the house so let's go to the Senate so
uh but obviously this is a a ma one of
the major things we have to talk about
as commission as we move forward uh and
like you said I mean it's it's a bill so
the next legisl you can we always change
it so um dick yeah thank you um well I'm
also on ways and means uh as are others
here and um house ways means um and uh
uh supported this amendment uh and uh
continue to support it and one uh under
understanding that we all have just
mentioned by representative set is that
um that what is uh done today can be
changed tomorrow by uh the legislature
and um in this case I think this is an
issue that the commission will be
looking at um and um essentially this
provision keeps alive our options uh to
to look at uh whether there should be uh
additional expansion or tighten probably
not tightening up very much CU it's hard
to go back once you've opened the door
and this uh this closes the door but
that door can be open a crack
or a little more and um so we can look
at it in that regard we're not uh we're
not uh facing a um complete opening of
the door such that when we get around to
making our
recommendations um you know the barn
door has been opened and it'll be hard
to close it I didn't say that very
clearly but I do I do um uh support this
uh change that we're going to be voting
on pretty soon and um and see it as
preserving the uh
um
uh the situation so the commission can
speak to it um and do de a deeper dive
than we were able to do at Ways and
Means okay thank you dick um any other
comments on that okay back to the back
to the rent
issue uh um I think we probably would
have wound up there at this point uh
that we would we would get rid of the
rid of the R again my only
concern is for the smaller places I'm
this big picture now there was a reason
why there was rent and that this is
before HHR HHR times and all of that and
that was that you know this is evolved
from m i call Mom and Pop mom and pop
facilities that were hey Charities come
help us come we're we're going to create
a place we have table games and you you
come in and in your charity can sponsor
nights and by the way it's a risk to us
and to hedge against the risk I must
some of the legislators at the time must
said okay well I'll rent to protect the
bad days in other words it could be that
we're you know we're having a couple of
days there was snow days whatever they
still stay off the tables and they
didn't make any money on it so so they
decided that okay they could charge
rent uh I think we're beyond that when
you look at the numbers the numbers the
revenues are really getting bigger and
bigger uh but there's still a few small
ones uh when I look at at North
Northwoods
Casino who's that who's
Northwoods burin right so they uh from
the data that Charlie provided us the
$106,000 uh for one year and the and I
did the math backwards so that meant uh
that that was the 35% allocation so the
other 65% was about
197,000 so combined that's around I
don't know down about
300 uh about yeah around three just call
300,000 in Revenue
uh it seems
like I've talked to some people about
this it seems like the association of
these these locations these
organizations has support of of all all
of the
facilities
uh what I'm getting at is
that I think we I think we in a position
right now to take a position on this uh
do we want to hear from some of smaller
locations uh before we we weigh in on
the rent issue because my goal is to try
to take one of these issues at a time
and and take it off the table and say
look let's vote on it and move on to
something else to talk about um um so I
think we're pretty close to saying yeah
I mean Fred your bill trying to jump the
gun a little bit that's fine but as
commission I think rent the time of
rents is long gone it sounds like the
association is agreeing with that
so
yeah so again I think that apologize for
my voice but I think that um Again The
Operators have come to an agreement that
this is an okay provision they're okay
with removing rent as an organiz as a uh
organization so you know we can take our
position of what we want but just
understand the people are going to be
getting the money or saying no we're
okay with not take getting the money so
right so I yeah I just say one thing on
that so I think the association if I'm
not mistaken is good with it but tied to
the moratorium if the moratorium doesn't
happen then it could be a financial
burden on some of the smaller properties
okay so that's an interesting piece of
information because I mean I can
understand that
um without the
moratorium I mean this is a big issue
for us to discuss as we move forward I
mean how how many these facilities do we
really want in the state I mean if if we
weren't talking charitable gaming we're
talking real casinos we wouldn't be
talking about 19
casinos um and and then the other issue
is not just casinos but how many how
many historic racing machines how many
historic racing machines do we think is
reasonable now we know in the
legislature we know that there's free
market let the market dictate that let
the market dictate how many machines let
the doet dictate how many
locations but we know the more there are
and there going to be survival of of
Fitts out
there uh but but when we look at other
states they all restrict the number of
locations no okay Charlie help me out it
does huh L it does Nevada you can get a
license in Nevada on Nevada okay so
there's one on Nevada is Nevada and also
the number of states it's limited Tri
tribal as well likeed trib we have to
word we don't have that issue so but
those those are isses we got to address
um so dick I know you had your okay your
I I think two things become having been
around this business for a few years I I
would I would say to you that
proliferation has always been a
concerned we we were opposed more than
one for 20 years so uh now we're talking
about
19 uh how much how much will will this
community will this community called do
him should bear in terms of the number
of entities that that are are in place I
I think it's imperative that we put a
number in place we're talking about pop
and we're talking about the number of
dispensaries that that we can have so
we're we're in the we're in the habit of
of of creating a situation where there's
a certain number that are that that
required I I think it's an imperative
and with regard to the red boo boo Dell
put all of this together in the in the
Senate a number of years ago that's
where the 35% came from and that's where
all of the abilities that were were put
in place were were developed we did that
in set it ways and meanss and I think
the house accepted
that I I I don't think that there was
any appreciation for the expansion that
has taken place over the last few years
and and certainly with the Advent of
historic horse racing machines you got
another entity that's in the mix now
that uh plays a significant
role and whether you equate it with a
with a slot machine or or or or not it
is what it is and uh I I I think
proliferation certainly the the vendors
I mean those who are who are operating
are going to have a distinct opinion of
this you got to limit this thing to a
certain number chis otherwise it's it
just gets out of hand I I mean how many
how many chly do we really have an
operation as we
speak uh it's 10 now and I think I sent
out to the sub committee there are 1,00
machines in activity currently uh that
number is proposed to grow um and I
would submit you know do 10 hot dog
stands at 10 restaurants I I don't know
I would the machines are what concern me
in terms of the number in the
proliferation more than the number of
facilities does um that to me is a
bigger concern than um the number of
facilities like I to me there should
almost be a quota system for machines
like but then again you're getting
protectionist or do we set a set a limit
on locations and times
and it seems to be on one hand we're
being protectionist and the other hand
we're saying let the free market decide
well well I think look at if I might Mr
look at what we've done with the time
the the time element that's now
available you can open at 8:00 in the
morning you could go until what 2 3
4: that that's that's an enormous
movement in in one One Direction that
was never Vision uh in in the early
stages of of this activity so I I I
agree with you when you talk about
machines and the number and the number
of
machines that becomes another I think a
very interesting situation here you if I
good Mr chairman the the vast bulk of
the machines that are proposed will be
on the southern border and so the to
representative Jet's point about Salem
they're going to Bear the brunt of the
activity yeah versus like for example
North Country yeah just because of the
population density population density is
a given in gambling it's a variable that
matters
tremendously um ter for the math and for
the
revenues yes so again I I think we
recognize this when we put rules in
place the idea was using the revenue
multiplier as a way of controlling um
the difference between a game of chance
and a historical horse racing and how
much that balance could look like and
maybe that's the appropriate place we
look maybe not the number of locations
but how that balance plays out right
again the idea was we wanted to
encourage more games of chance but allow
for uh HHR and so a multiplier was put
in to keep a ratio between those two
things um so that was the way I think we
looked at it um when we when we passed
this was a way of managing and
controlling this was using that ratio of
gaming table games and GES a chance to
machine
B okay again we're not going to solve
this today but this this is this is
going to be the Crux of
again the information we get from the
Consultants will be helpful too on this
issue um Charlie pend
out yeah it's just a sort of a breakdown
sorry it's a breakdown of the number of
machines per capita and where we lie on
that Spectrum we are less saturated than
Rhode Island we are more saturated than
Maine in terms of machines per person
already right the 19 we you say we have
1900 23 machines yes that's correct that
that'll fluctuate given the day there
not that's just a snapshot when we got
that day I think from a day two days
before so it'll be around there but
it'll be growing over time I don't
imagine that number to get low lower so
without the without the gross that we're
anticipating in the state yes we're at
725 machines per capita all the way
around people per machine people's
people per machine correct and
Massachusetts
1353 P machine yeah and the average in
New England of those States was I
believe 788 so we're slightly more
saturated than average so Mr chair yeah
I'm I'm curious as to why Connecticut
wasn't included was curios they're
tribal they're tribal casinos and their
relationship is not statutory based it
was it's limited wholly by
um I don't know what the machines are
currently but there was the time
Foxwoods and we some with the two
biggest casinos in the world so they
would probably have upwards of 10,000 I
believe and so they would be 10,000
divided by 3 million you're talking 300
per person 300 people per machine no
just
curiosity was their their growth and
derivation was litigation number of
lawsuits the tribes Su the state of
concut
so okay so uh I think the discussion on
the on on rent
uh I think we are in agreement but I I'm
going to hold off to maybe the meeting
at two from now we we'll actually vote
on that as to that we we think R should
should uh be eliminated although there
was a little caveat
here uh that it would be tied the folks
from the especially the small location
wanted to make sure there was a cap on
it so maybe we will hold off a little
too yeah Mr chairman I just wanted to
mention you know given that tie that tie
is effectively in s sp12 because while
we're putting a moratorium in um you
know you and removing rent it's not like
if that passes you can suddenly you know
what I mean it's already tied it's
already so if that's why that's why I
was thinking about it saying we'll hold
off on that because it's part of the
larger discussion at the end right okay
thank
you all right so let's anything else on
on those okay so uh last meeting Charlie
handed
out this
document we never really went through it
which is kind of like it really it
covers main massachusett Rhode Island
and New Hampshire and pairs them uh what
those States have
States but I don't know the folks bring
those with them good yep yep with the
for
so I just I just thought we could go
through this real quick Charlie
um first off what's a racino
[Laughter]
uh it's a term of Art in the industry
where based on the having been a track
horse track mostly before sometimes Dog
Tracks the operat the owner operator is
able to get machines and it's often used
to to support the
indigenous racing industry for example
like a Kentucky or
um um West Virginia it was actually used
West Virginia casinos part of their
requirement is that they fund dog racing
in West Virginia in fact West Virginia
is the only state in the US that still
has live dog racing and it was used to
fund and part of the requirement to get
the license to open a casino is you
spend seven figures supporting dog
racing in the state that's sort of what
a Racino is so that was Hollywood Casino
and correct and similar to Oxford Casino
had been a racetrack by Mr Bear right uh
and which he sold to churel Downs Church
Downs now owns that facility right
okay
uh so we have main key if we go to main
key
facts uh it seems like every state taxes
differently every state uh and then
Massachusetts of course they figured out
how to tax every little thing you know
everybody has their fingers in who's
Maine
uh did this Define the difference
between the gross slot revenue and the
net I think I know what it is but can
is um
well I actually don't know it but I'm
sorry this was prepared for by one of
the folks I work with in terms so I
actually don't know how I'm being
defines it because that would matter i'
have to check with them and he's not
here right now he's not here right now
no I know net slot income is what's left
at the um in the machine at the end of
the day in terms of what is gets divied
up uh and how that gets divied up Maine
as I recall has about
seven tributaries off of their revenue
as to where the money goes and I have to
bring them for you get them for you I
literally just did this as sort of
something as a reference point I wasn't
happy to have gone through it um a
little more detailed but not prepared to
do it today right
okay um and then you give a table of
what the total taxes
are
um but then on top of the taxes and this
something that that we don't have in New
Hampshire correct me if I'm wrong I mean
we have license
fees for certain things but I'm sure
there just reasonable license fees yeah
there's no commas H there are no commas
in license fees no
no uh but in Maine you want a casino
operator's license that's 225,000
what's a what's a slot machine
distributor license if you distributor
of slot machines right so it would be
answorth Konami so if they Wonder all so
so if they if they want to do business
in Maine that's
$200,000 and well these are annual or
this
I guess the casino operator licensees an
initial and then and then future years
right yeah so if you looked on the table
Yeah renewal renewals Z 75,000
yep we don't have any of that correct
okay like I said there are there are
fees I think the license fee Val come
wrong for operator is
$750 yeah
$750 for an operator
okay all right uh
[Music]
um table game fees 100,000 you know okay
so that's just one example main um
Massachusetts which invents every tax in
the
world um they have three casinos we know
all know about Encore and the
Springfield location and then they
basically have a a a slot paror I would
call it uh plane ridge they still just
slot machines there yes right
um so let's go through the
numbers
um so just just for comparison I mean
Encore I guess Encore in uh in the
Springfield their initial fee was 85
million yeah yep
uh but and they also had a guarantee
that their minimum investment that
they're going to build a nice facility
was $500 million hotel with
Hotel um so there were certain
restrictions in it and then a tax of 25%
on on net slot machine and table gain
revenues yeah it also if I recall
correctly there's also a requirement
that the Juris get something too U from
each of those as well but there's a
there's a there's a takeout for them as
well it's a couple of percent per I
think it's three for the host and 1% for
the surrounding so that they can deal
with the social issues and pay
lake in the category two license looks
like it's just slot is a plane field
yeah yeah yeah so plane field just for
slot machines was prage was uh $25
million up front and minimum investment
million
um actually it was their ones saw
Garfield of Simon and gar Garfunkle s
golle
fame
um I I didn't play the machines but I
wanted the event there uh and then
there's 49% net on the uh on the net
slot machine
income
so Pat can I ask a question yeah sure
and it's going to be for Aaron because
it's a gaming operator question so
interesting I'm looking at Massachusetts
facts I look at encor I look at MGM
Springfield right two two significant
casinos one seems to almost have an
equal distribution between slot revenue
and I'm going to for our purposes
consider that HHR revenue and table gain
revenue right they're they're pretty
evenly divided and then you go to MGM
and it's nowhere near it's the table
games are one quarter is that having to
do with marketing the operator what
they're looking for in a player and what
we what they're emphasizing in their
facility or is that just happen to be a
weird coincidence um you know I can't
answer that off the top of my head but a
lot of it has to do with the
demographics and table games players
usually eat at more highend restaurants
lot machine players
buffets um the Asian demographic which
Boston assuming has a lot more tends to
lean towards table games versus um I
know it's a lot smaller in Springfield
so I think it's a bunch of factors all
build that thank
you
okay and then then there's a
whole there's a whole slew of
Massachusetts there's a whole slew of
other
fees
um and monies that have to go to places
here I'm not quite sure I know you
didn't pull this together Charlie
but uh regulatory
costs is that above the percentage from
the from the games in the in the slot
machines no I think that that's the the
budget of the gaming commission I do
know that there's an additional tax on
machines in Massachusetts which is $600
per machine per year I think that's what
it goes towards if I recall
correctly okay so you look down there's
a per EG e g under the mass law it's
defined as an electronic gaming device
if I recall correctly every law
considers the machine not every law
there are variances amongst laws as to
what it's called sometimes it's called a
video Lottery terminal some it's called
the you know uh EGD R so it's called HHR
uh that just it varies by the definition
of of the
statute
okay again there's a there's a variety
of of fees here above and beyond the
normal tax I guess is what it said
Island
tton
um so again Charlie what's it what's it
they have rter they called video Lottery
terminals correct um Rhode Island is a
story unto itself um that would take me
a long time to explain um IGT which is
the biggest I think still either the
first or second biggest slot
manufacturer in the world is also the
biggest lottery vendor in the world is
the biggest employer in Rhode
Island and so um they have
a they're very influential on the State
House of Rhode Island they've had the
Rhode Island contract for lottery and
for the systems at the casinos for
effort um and they just renewed for 20
years based on the terms you have here
um and
so they they've been a this it's just
been a state that's embraced gambling
time
okay say the extension to 2043 yeah
correct they had previously had a
2023 and they they they have again just
m it too they they want to make sure
that there's investment into these
facilities to make
them probably
multifaceted facilities I would
imagine um yeah Twin Rivers had actually
prior to we been a racetrack as
well and so it had the remnants of the
racetrack just didn't look particularly
nice and they wanted to upgrade
those
okay all right so
again it's there's a lot of apples and
oranges between the
states
um and that we've got a and then there's
a whole section here on New
Hampshire um
basically we're we're looking at 14
right now tend to have historic racing
machines uh and sports book is at seat
book Manchester over in ashaa
correct and then s cast is it
work
um we know about the 10% 35% and all
that but then just a nice table at the
end here but with the uh
as of the caly Year
22 for this six there were at the time
there were 16 locations I guess now
they're down to
14 that correct yeah sorry two the two
Keen locations merged okay and it was it
it was last year right yeah that's right
yeah
um and you can see in the chart I mean
in total gross
revenues um total gross resue was all
for one year was
73 call it 74
million of which the commission share
does that mean is that the state who's
the commission yeah that's us yeah yeah
the state 8 8.6 million and then the
charities
benefited 20.5
million and the the G the uh goes which
are the owners of these facilities um
again this is their
gr not their net revenue this is their
gross revenue before expenses 44.6
million so um I mean there's a this's a
good little chart to get a sense of the
wide
range of size of the facil
ities if if you if you look at if you
look at them they're smaller ones Mr
chairman if I could certainly I'm happy
to update these numbers the next meeting
because we will have calendar year
presuming we not have a meeting before
Christmas uh for calendar year 23 as
great
document
shows you how these states I mean they
they they micro this I mean you know we
tend to send money to the general fund
or send it to the education trust fund
or whatever here the earmark there's a
lot of ear marking going on with where
the money
goes I mean they a mark the city of
Bangor gets 1% they
get um you know we may we may get to
that by the way as we discuss this uh
that because there is some discussion
that that some of these these fac especi
facilities get
larger that some of these communities
are saying hey you know it's costing us
money to to
uh provide police uh coverage in the
evening some
nighttime
um I mean they I me they got things like
05% goes to the main milk
pool 0.15% goes to main Maritime Academy
you know they really
earmark um things
and then Massachusetts
is actually that Maine was even more so
than than ma massachus your
marks I mean yeah say 40% goes to the
education trust
fund
uh uh this two and a half% goes to the
racehorse Development Fund um I don't
know they do they still have do they
still have live
racing didn't they close the one yeah
there was um that they're closed there's
racing so
again as far as I know we all the EX's
all right now all the excess State
money goes to the education trust
fund
that yeah I I
think I think the pictures a little bit
different because um in New Hampshire
what we're doing is we're
allocating the revenues that aren't
going to be kept by The Operators to the
general fund but also to
Charities and so there's a big chunk of
money that's going to Charities and no
other state is doing that but they're
doing a lot of other things and that's
the long list we're seeing under
Massachusetts and so forth
and the other thing I wanted to say is
this is exactly the information that I
hope the consultant that gets the job
helps us um sort through and separate
and be able to compare apples to apples
and oranges to oranges because it's hard
right now and so um New Hampshire
doesn't have a big LIC licensing fee and
access to the entitlement to to operate
these facilities but
um we've got other things and other
states are getting a lot of money so
people say to me well why aren't we
getting $25 million for you know for the
next historic course racing machine
operator that's going to have a thousand
machines let's say and so forth um we've
got to be able to sort through um this
I think that there is one other
state when would when Delaware began
this process and Delaware was what the
they were the initial entry and they had
three tracks They had Delaware Park they
had they had do downs and Harington
they're still running those three tracks
are still running uh two years ago or
three years ago pressure was put on
Delaware to put charitable gabing into
all of these facilities so they that
have charitable gaming they still have I
think they still maintain the initial
situation that existed the big the big
ticket items cost but there is a
charitable gam component I don't know
how that's handled but the woman who
runs the delw lottery is a full of
Representative uh and uh heled uh I
don't know what hel's last name is but
but anyway she runs and I'm in contact
with but I know that they have
charitable gabing so at least there's
there's somebody who we can look at who
deals with charitable gabing in the true
sense of the word charitable gabing uh I
don't know how many other states have it
as as as we do but it in in Delaware it
sits upon an organization that began
with with the lottery becoming the place
where gaming was expanded bines at the
at the track
dollarss allocated for horse
racing uh uh at at doels there's a car
track that that's there so they take
care of they take care of that they
still maintain standard bread racing
there and Harington is a fair type of
situation which would be more more more
like an agrarian situation all right
that's that's the southern part of of
the of the T but there's a good example
for us to look at of an existing
situation that then Place charitable gam
on top of it and what's happened as a
result of that what the Charities get
versus what's the the general the
general situation with regarding the
watery and how much do the watery takes
out of this and and with where the money
goes there because when you look at
what's in place at our sister
States you you look at the the initial
cost to get into the business and
getting into the business is quite
expensive it's a multi-billion dollar
situation for us to get in the business
it's what
$575 or something like that $750
$750 compared to 35 billion there's a
huge differential there and that that
certainly shows up a bit of better here
but on the other side the Charities if
you look at what the charities can't
here versus there is there aren't any
Charities the other jurisdictions other
than the one that I articulated on
Delaware so when you when you give it 20
billion to Charities based on the
numbers that we've seen here uh $2
billion is a lot of money it's it's a
lot of
money and we're going to have to look at
that because anything that disturbs that
would be problematic I I think you know
quite
problematic yes Tim so I'm I'm assuming
we're just talking now about General
Revenue and revenue sharing and how that
Revenue sharing is occurring and as I
said in the RFP process the state takes
a unique process and we take that 35%
and give it to Charities we just choose
not to do the individual allocations
we're letting the operators pick the
Charities and do those Charities but but
make no mistake that un that's still a
state required expense or or Draw out of
funds that are happening for an operator
so when we're talking about percentages
and what percentages look like the
effective rate if you combine HHR and
and games of chance the effective tax
rate is
35% right that's our effective tax rate
that we're requiring out of the revenues
that the that operators make and
understand that out of the remaining 66%
The Operators keep they still have to
pay business profits tax they still got
to pay business Enterprise tax so I'm
not even sure that 35% is an effective
rate when you add in all those other um
taxes they have to pay that they get to
the state local property taxes that go
into that as well that come out of their
66% so I'm hoping as we talk about this
and what that really looks like I I
don't want to walk around walk out of
here thinking that the operators are
stealing right they that they're just
making money hand over fist because
there are a lot more requirements and a
lot more um expenses that are on the
other side and I'm not justifying
anything other than just to make that
statement to make sure we're clear when
we talk about our numbers right they
have a just on their base gross revenue
absent all those other expenses they
have a 35% tax rate on on their revenues
and then on top of that they have all
those local things and all the other
state taxes they've got to pay um and so
their effective tax rate is probably
much higher than that than it would be
for other businesses in the same you
know just a regular business so I I just
want to make sure we're taking into
account that whole big picture of what
that looks like I I look at the 35% they
do for charitable gain ging on the on
the games of chance side is basically
the
state saying we're not going to
micromanage this we're going to let you
deal with it right we're going to just
make let you do the grants locally and
and and not have to have that at the
stakes I can't imagine the finance
committee having to figure that out um
and so uh and distributing those funds
so as as we're looking at this I just
want to make sure we're taking a
holistic look at everything and the
revenues and the fees being charged to
operators um that are Beyond just as
simple what what what's the split look
like right and understand that I was
just going to say uh it's actually 35
plus 10 the state so 45 tot right so
understand our goal is to look we're not
taking anybody's side on this we're
saying what's fair to the state what's
fair to the organizations that have
facilities that have offered these games
and what's fair to the
Charities and and that's what we're
trying to get at uh we're not saying
that it's not fair
now uh but we don't know uh so we're
that's why we're going to bring these
consultants in help us at least compare
as best we can apples to apples to make
sure that we're uh you know we are we're
being fair look we're not going to
dismantle charitable gaming in the state
no way I mean charitable gaming is here
to stay and I I know they cars me say
this all the time but but it's here
today day but it's changed so much that
we've we
it's good that we have this Commission
because we need to pause and look at at
kind of what's going on in the industry
here uh we we really don't have any
there's only one local owner at this
point of all all of them which is fine
they're outside
owners uh but that's all happened in the
last five years where it's it's all
changed on us I mean uh and and the
whole issue of how many and all of that
you know we can all be free market types
and say let the let the market dictate
it and uh but you know I don't think all
the existing CH locations are really
going to be excited about that um
but or we could say look let's limit it
uh clearly everybody's going to want to
be in the Southern Tier because that's
what the population
is uh but you know maybe we want we want
to help more Charities up in North
Country and the way we can do that by
having more facilities up North so maybe
we need to weigh in some of those issues
as we as we talked you know maybe maybe
Geographic allocation of some of these
up north do you want to weigh in on
that yes I want you know one of
the Geniuses if you want here that out
the charal gaming is really distribution
if you look at that the various other
states it goes to government government
is taking this and government says these
are the good
programs with our charal gaming the uh
various um organizations if you want are
are going over sponsoring 10 days a year
but it's going to that little
organization if you want okay unknown
one that cares for maybe uh Sisters of
the blind if you want okay they've got
15 volunteers who are putting in
countless hours if you want in there but
only part of those hours again have been
trying to fundraise all of a sudden that
$5,000 possibly comes in because they
were sponsor H go over Revitalize their
their the organization and I can go over
and provide more service and it's those
unknown ones that th those particular
small
organizations uh can go to a can knock a
Delaware NS if you want door it say hi
this is our Delaware North looks at it H
not worth it okay we'd rather give our
our money to the cancer fund to the uh
to the big names again you get the
recognition so it's it's those small
ones that really end up by
multiplying if you want those dollars
because even the local
communities are don't have budgets to go
over and necessarily fund that
particular
organizations um services so that those
kind of Fall by the wayside because
they're small and our teral gaming goes
over and is able to go over and address
some of those and I would certainly
agree that the North country you know
again has got to be looked at but the
North Country organizations can apply if
you want and sponsor if you want the um
uh 10 days in Nash in Salem Manchester
if you want they're not the the sponsors
are not limited as to where they are in
the state that just have to be a chable
organization
right
well thank you for that
um I'd like to spend the rest of the the
day talking about the Charities because
that's basically why we're
handout and then I also invited we have
an invited guest here today
um Kathleen Reen who will introduce in a
minute uh I just want to start the
discussion about
Charities and uh I'm not saying again
this is to me this is all a blank sheet
of paper um we don't necessarily want to
we're helping a lot of Charities now
there's no question about it um
Charities are making over
$100,000
today uh
it's kind of hard to say to them well
we're going to pull a rug out from
you going
forward uh but I had a few thoughts
about just to get the conversation going
and then we'll hear from Mr
R uh about our Charities and it's um I
mean the question of who selects the
Charities who schedules the
Charities maximum maximum number of days
per charity we know it's
10 uh in statute but doesn't mean every
charity gets 10 days currently it's up
to the facility some facilities don't
give they give seven days well they may
say we only G give you five or we have
three extra days who wants the three
extra
days um the obligation of the
charity we could say well well it's just
random we're picking Charities but if I
was a facility why why wouldn't I select
a charity to be in my portfolio
charities
um because they actually work it they
bring they bring people in because
they're promoting they do a good job of
promoting the event that the the 10 days
that they
have
uh and then it was brought up about the
uh daily posting of Charities at the
facilities I think who was it
represented brudy did you bring that one
up last time about about some of the
Charities not properly posted saying the
you
right
right right so then
thank you um the categories of
Charities I mean there's different
missions different sizes different
needs that I can see Charlie provided
the great list of all the Charities that
are being helped right now that are
participating and it's a wide broad list
of Charities all over the
place you know can we categorize those
Charities into different groups I was
told by potential new Charities that
want to be involved when I said well you
know you can make a 100 you can make 100
if you pick the right facility and they
they accept you and you get 10 days you
can make a hundred
$100,000 they go wow we don't need that
much
money uh is there again this is all
thinking out loud here uh in terms of do
we even want to touch the way things are
done with the Charities or not um but
again it's it's a charity is not a
charity it's not a charity
either um
but then how do we accommodate more
Charities this is the the problem we got
is that as more more Charities find out
about this more and more Charities want
to be involved now at least we did with
historic racing machines is we doubled
the number of Charities two two
Charities sponsoring one
date and by the way a facility can't
open unless they have the sponsors there
which is different than any other state
any other location that you can't open
for business if you don't have a sponsor
uh by a charity so it's really in a way
the charity is the kind of weing the dog
a little
bit I mean it's just the way it was been
structured I mean that's the way it is
no charities no you can't
open and then uh and then any sealing on
annual winnings my concern is if if some
of the facilities
grow
uh you know everybody's going to want
those that that facility to have dates
if it's only two dates my gosh you
know should there be some kind of a
ceiling and I again we're not going to
hurt again I would not do anything here
that was going to hurt any existing
Charities uh that that have done a good
job all these years I don't think we
have to we have we have to make sure
that and that's what we did by historic
racing by and the way we phased in
historic racing we made sure we
protected the the Legacy Charities that
were already
involved uh
but um but you know there's going to
come a point
where there there 100,000 or is it
125,000 should there be a ceiling I'm
posing this as a question I don't
know
but is going to come a time that is it
better to is it better to say that
we limit the days from 10 is that a way
you control this to to make sure but
like let's let's pick a
um look as as some of these Charities
grow and they add more
machines because we have no restrictions
on how many they can add if they decide
to add another wing and um and we still
have only two dates I mean so now the
existing charities make
150,000
160,000 uh or is it better to say well
let's share the
wealth and open it up to more Charities
again a way you can do that is by
reducing the days statutorily from 10 to
8 or something like that so this is all
open open questions for me uh that we
have to deal with as a group here so I
just wanted to start that thought
process going here
by having my short list here of things
uh not that we're going to accomplish
that today but what I I'd like to do is
to ask Kathleen Reen who's the uh chair
or the president the
chair of the
uh of the New Hampshire Center for
nonprofits thank you can just say one
thing so two things on that is that I
also want to remind everybody that the
statute doesn't require 10 days statute
is up to 10 days operator could split
their week up if they chose to and have
smaller Charities have two days a week
and have M five charities in a 10-day
period rather than one so by Statute
they already have the flexibility
operators too to be able to work with
smaller Charities if they want to and
break up the revenue stream in a
different manner um and then on top of
that again I just we do have
restrictions on the number of machines
they can have and we do that by the
revenue ratio
so um so I so we do have a metric that
we could control the number of machines
that metric is through the revenue
ratios and but I can I can add a wing
and add more table games too right sure
but you also have to make the revenue on
those table games so you can't if you
put the wing in you don't make any money
you can't increase your HHR
machines Mr chair I'd like to mention as
a charity representative as well that
the Charities when we doubled up started
making at least where we benefit made
less the following year once they
doubled up because the even though we're
tier one it still didn't make up for it
in revenue from the expansion let's say
of the machines right so the doubling up
that comes into account and where I work
as well there's about 10 Charities that
I had that ended up benefiting somewhere
else because of the doubling up of the
Charities if any charity is not
benefiting I would urge them to reach
out to any room because they're all
looking and they're actually scooping up
from each other to get Charities on the
list in order to be compliant and be
said say say that char No So to that
point um you're gonna get a saturation
point of Charities that want to
engage like we're almost to the point of
if we were to double the number of rooms
we couldn't meet the number of Charities
like level okay well this was an
interesting uh
sorry uh um fine you know actually there
are
Charities that are don't want to raise
money through gaming I mean it's just a
reality so okay well with that uh M Ren
uh thank you for being here uh like to
hear from what you have to say and what
your organization um some ideas that you
may have great well thank you uh
chairman uh abami and members of the
committee and giving me me this
opportunity to present here my goal
today is to let you know a little bit
about the center and also about
Charities um and not necessarily the
getting into the details of what you've
talked about today um so as for the
record um my name is Kathleen Ren I'm
the CEO of the New Hampshire Center for
nonprofits with more than 700 nonprofit
members the center exists to strengthen
and give voice to our nonprofit sector
we provide a broad Brad array of
programming Educational Tools and
resources so that nonprofit boards and
staff leaders can manage um and govern
their organizations effectively the
center is widely recognized as the go-to
resource
forers um and we provide a wide array of
programs and
services um over the last couple of
years we've provided 45 to 50
educational programs each year that
reach 2500 participants on on a wide
array of topics um including financial
management
fundraising uh marketing and and more
our signature Hoffman House Fellowship
helps prepare Rising board leaders for
nonprofit board service and we've helped
about
26 uh 213 people have graduated from
that program we host monthly peer Circle
organ uh programs for executive
directors to learn from each other get
guidance um share expertise and uh best
practices and our annual nonprofit
Leadership Summit and policy caucuses
brings together nonprofit leaders
Business Leaders Community leaders to
look at policy issues current trends and
other issues impacting the nonprofit
sector New Hampshire gives is the
state's largest day of giving the center
coordinates that and since Inception um
more than $12 million has been raised
for a th000 nonprofits participating in
in that 24-hour online giving
event more than 6,700 people um receive
our newsletters which are full of
information and tools and resources for
their organizations um as well as job
postings in the nonprofit sector um and
even more go to our website where we
have a lot of resources templates and
tools we work to elevate the visibility
of the nonprofit sector and its impact
on our state and we advocate for
policies that help nonprofit profets
Advance their missions and serve our
communities many of you have talked um
today about Charities um and I just want
to reiterate how important they are in
our state our state is home to more than
7,000 501c3 nonprofit organizations that
address an AR astounding array of needs
they Steward our natural and C cultural
resources they help us care for people
of all
ages they um educate us and enrich our
lives and the typical nonprofit in New
Hampshire is small um 71% have revenues
under
$100,000 at the same time they are
powerful economic Source in our state
that the last um last time that figures
were available 15% of the state's
Workforce is employed by a
nonprofit as we've all gone through the
co pandemic um covid-19 pandemic many
people have really begin to recognize
how important nonprofits are to our
communities and here in New Hampshire
our state government relies on
nonprofits to deliver a lot of critical
essential Services everything from
providing Health Care H housing the
homeless feeding the hungry supporting
our elderly providing child care and so
much more Falls to nonprofit
organizations where in many other states
these are government um
services today nonprofits are helping
address our most pressing needs and
they're doing so at a time with
increased needs in the community growing
demand for their services Rising costs
and many of you may know that financing
a nonprofit is a very complex issue
nonprofits rely on a wide array of
Revenue Services Revenue sources
including some have grants um and
contracts with state and federal
government they rely on philanthropic
support Investments program fees and
more other incom as well for many
nonprofits charitable gaming is an
important part of the revenue
mix we're pleased to um help the
commission as you consider um oh I have
one more thing wait this is a vulnerable
time for the nonprofit sector like their
for-profit um counterparts we're facing
Workforce challenges wage pressures
Rising expenses but unlike for-profit
companies we can't simply raise our
prices in order to support we need to
um rely on this diverse mix of Revenue
source and contracts with government and
philanthropy which often don't cover the
full costs of doing business as a
nonprofit we're pleased to work with the
commission as you um invite Charities to
come in so that you can hear um from
their experience about how charitable
gaming supports them we begun reaching
out to some of our members and we would
invite a group here that would represent
the diversity of mission the diversity
of geography um working with different
game operators as well as the size of
the organization so you can understand
how important it is to various um
Revenue
mixes as this commission reviews
potential changes to charitable gaming
laws I urge you to keep in
mind that gaming exists in New Hampshire
to support our Charities that is the
regulational construct that was passed
um and these Charities these very
Charities are so important to our states
and our communities thank
you thank you thank you for that um let
so of your Charities that you represent
uh what what perent would you say are
adverse to charitable gaming in terms of
just because it's it's
gambling um or that that they all
would like to see Char gaming uh
enhanced even more I I don't have data
about what charities positions are I
think you can see that a number of
Charities have seen that revenue is an
important part of their mix um certainly
every every charity would you know have
that conversation with their board about
how that aligns with their mission
um okay so do
you um in terms of knowledge about
charitable gaming is it safe to say that
your membership is well aware of
charitable gaming that it
exists um I think that a lot of
Charities are aware of that and there's
more education um we we had a forum uh
last Friday in which we talked about
charitable gaming and um representative
from the commission came as well and
talked about it so it is something that
not every organization knows how to
access um but you know there's broad
awareness increasing awareness of it as
a
option thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you for taking my question um just in
general um the 700 members of the New
Hampshire
Center are we using the word nonprofit
and charity synonymously is every
nonprofit a
charity it so in terms of the 7,000
number the 7,000 nonprofits are the five
in the state of New Hampshire are 501c3
is based in New Hampshire providing
services in New Hampshire um the center
and our members includes nonprofits of
various types of nonprofits um the bulk
of them are charitable
nonprofits is that is that your question
does that address your question okay so
yeah so so it's not necessarily
synonymous a lot of nonprofits are
Charities but not all not all nonprofits
are Charities not all not all nonprofits
are Charities but the vast majority are
but there are like 20 different um sub
sectors of the of the
charitable um you know there's 51c 3s
and sixes and 19s and all of those and
this I don't I don't know all of the um
this RSA charitable gaming is open
to I think six different types um so it
is primarily charitable but like there's
five y Ma and cheating okay
but like veterans veterans groups are
you know have are not
all corre eligible I think it's a
handful I get you the list if you want
sorry no no yeah get you the list it's
not all of them but it's closely defined
I think we should all see yeah yeah so
we can we pull the RSC
okay
good um yeah actually question Charlie
just CU I I want to make sure I'm
clearing it so again there's no
Geographic correlation but between a
charity and a gaming operator so someone
from Berlin can be working with nsha
there's no there's no n there's no
required there's almost a natural one
though right obviously to come in but if
they the Charities can The Operators can
accept from anywhere in the state as
long as they meet the 50c requirement
correct correct thank you Fred Fred has
a question uh thank you Mr chair and
thanks for taking my question I'm just
pretty unfamiliar with your organization
is there a a resource that I can use to
see who the 700 plus members are we
folks started how you started that kind
of thing you have a website or something
yep we have a website nhn nonprofits.
org um and you can look at uh we have
our list of members is
there as well as information about all
of our programs and services that I
referenced quick
followup do you know off hand how many
of your members are currently engaged
with charitable
gaming I don't have that exact number no
guess
um how many how many Charities are
are present involved with presently
involved
yeah sorry there's a strong I I guess
what I would say the max the minimum
would be 104 per
location no I I get that my question was
she she represents a group of Charities
or nonprofits and I'm wondering how many
of those are involved at present to to
your knowledge if you don't don't know
if we can find that out I'd be
you so my thought is
that that the that the the commission
have a u additional public input from
Charities uh at some point maybe next
meeting or the meeting
after uh and I'd like to get a cross
section of the charities
and I was going to ask Miss W to help us
with that to give us a
cross-section um of the types of
facilities or Charities that are out
there
um um without objection is that okay
with everybody so okay so uh any other
questions
of just for clarity we we have two
members on the board here that on on the
commission that are representative of
the Charities are you saying a component
if I'm reading you right Mr chair a
component from this group is going to I
mean I want to hear from
everybody well we can't hear from well
we can't hear from everybody well
there's 800 plus Charities that are
actively involved I think we should hear
to the extent that we can but you're not
isolating Our Testimony to one group
presenting oh oh no no no no the no
individual Charities but what I'm
looking for is a cross-section of
Charities you know I we don't you know I
don't want to hear from every Boys and
Girls Club but one Boys and Girls Club
huh
so would perhaps written testimony make
sense if we had some Charities maybe
write some written testimony and
everybody can kind of peruse over it not
their
pleasure yeah I I've been I was in
that but I would agree with said I'm
just questioning like how many want to
have it's better to get people in front
of us okay to talk how many how many do
you have kind of in mind well if each
could go five minutes and we given you
know like uh so open it up and give
everybody five about about maybe 10 to
12 charities okay something like that
good to know thank
you well I guess our charity
Representatives uh I mean we have the I
mean we technically have the list of all
the
Charities uh so uh but I just wanted to
look for somebody who has a maybe our
two charity members can offer up some
thoughts about as well uh the a
cross-section of the kind of Charities
yeah hello mran uh can you give us an
idea maybe not today but in the future
as to whether or not your membership
looks at the current system as being
advantageous to their missions in other
words would they pre would they prefer a
situation where uh there is Mission
directed monies from charitable gaming
versus uh just the luck of the night so
if one one charity gets a Wednesday
night versus one getting a Saturday uh
and I know very little about the
statistics of this but if uh that uh
that Wednesday night doesn't prove to be
a great night for gaming for whatever
reason but Saturday nights are fantastic
uh in some cases that might be the luck
of the draw what I think we would like
to hear a little bit about is is the
actual Mission focused aspect of of
those monies and whether or not your
membership would prefer a system like
that
I think that's a a good reason to bring
some Charities here to hear directly
from them and we can certainly work on
on um on that as
well because I think the point is that
in
statute there's no direction as to other
than maximum of 10
days there's no anything about make sure
everybody gets a weekend or you know and
then you can say well we're we're
leaving up the facilities we are leaving
just right now we're leaving up
facilities to pick
which which Charities get which dates
and we all know there are good dates and
there are bad
dates uh I think most of them work
towards the ones that I talk to trying
to balance it out a little bit that
everybody gets you know some weekday
dates and some weekend dates uh you know
dates that are
more which have been more profitable for
everybody including the
Charities so uh but there's nothing in
statue that directs that I mean it's
just the way it works
um uh you know again as a commission is
there something we want to delve into I
I think we're going to we're going to
probably start delving into it a little
bit uh may not be that there's anything
different comes out the back end but I
think we need to have the conversation
about that and I I think having the
charity you put would be very valuable
to all of us on that um uh but like I
said earlier you know all Charities
aren't created equal all Charities don't
put as much effort into their dates in
terms of filling a room up with with
people saying promoting promoting their
dates hey we got these we got these 10
Dates you know people who like boys and
girls club in
wherever uh come on come on out to the
to whatever facility that's holding
those dates and and help us out that way
that's the way this was originally
intended to
work that the Charities would sponsor
the date when it used to be in the
church basement and the guy with the ru
wheel came to the church
basement that charity was really
promoting the
date you know so so there's value in in
that to me that the Charities are loing
the date because it's helping everybody
out and helps the state out too so uh so
again I'm just trying to go from where
we were to where we are
today and as to what the philosophies
are here um as we as we move forward um
you know what do we think that we need
to adjust our statutes accordingly but
uh that that's to be
seen um Mr chair just to as a chair to
speak to the weekend comment typically
we get seven days and it includes a
Monday to Sunday just for licensing
posting and those purposes it makes
sense to have them be in order um and
then typically if you do get up to 10
maybe one gets two weekends maybe one
gets one but I think everybody for the
most part and the lottery could speak
better to it with other rooms and
experiences but typically everybody gets
a
weekend Charlie yeah certainly if looked
at the reports that were sent two
meetings ago last meeting you'll see the
revenue the revenue generally reflects
the days you
got and so um if you they're all by done
by room all that report so you can see
which sort of are even and which are not
self-evident so again I guess what I'm
interested in hearing from Charities
about is again are there Charities or
have that had a difficulty and what was
that difficulty and is it a legislative
solution or just a operational problem
right so um I mean I think again for the
most part the up the the Charities are
are fairing well under charitable gaming
but the question is what are we missing
right so those people that had problems
wanted a date couldn't get a date people
who uh feel like they were short changed
in some way shape or form um let's have
those conversations and find out what
bring that to the light let's have that
conversation see if it's a statutory
problem or regulatory problem that that
this commission needs to look at but I I
I I guess I'm struggling to see if we
just have 10 or 12 Charities show up and
say nope things are great what's the
committee can I ask this question would
it make sense for us to send out a
um questionnaire sort of Survey Monkey
type thing we have all the email
addresses I
think by and large um a series of
questions and get back responses that
seems to be more of a broad-based sort
of res a great starting point to get
summary of the you know 800 Charities
that are out there and what their
experience has been working with the
operators I mean there are certain folks
that you know just don't have email I
think but yeah by and large I think we
could do that pretty
effectively okay that's that makes a lot
of sense so
s Charlie would you need some help with
creating the questions you I don't think
so certainly um I we do this a lot for
lots of things um so I think I can Kelly
would you please remind me I promise to
do this thank you
um um but certainly I I'll send a draft
before I send it out okay and so we can
add our right we can additional
questions I it's you know the way you
ask question on Research is incredibly
important so right it'll be very U
generic okay let this is good this is
good all right so I think we we're going
to do this first and then we'll then
we'll look at maybe inviting some in as
well yeah um was a good point Tim that
to brought it out so okay great well
thank you very
you Mr chairman I have a question for
the
director we got this sheet with all the
um
charity revenues on
it I was going to ask the question what
was the difference between a nonprofit
and a charity there's a lot of people on
the
sheet uh I know there's a couple of
Social Clubs a football club um and
they're collecting money mostly on Bingo
and Lucky Sevens but would these people
be eligible to apply for
um days at the casinos
yes it is and the the revenue is based
if you look at the across the grid the
ones that have HHR or the facilities
that have HHR so in some cases that
charity is not licensed at a facility
that has historic horse racing that's
why it's limited to Bing all lucky7 okay
and only I a followup I only asked
because you said not all nonprofits are
eligible correct so for example a
political action committee is
technically a not profit and it's not
eligible okay but anybody on this sheet
would be cor correct and it's it's
delineated in the RSA by the section of
the
501c that it falls under okay 51 C3
being the most popular but there's a
number of all right thank
you hey Charlie again maybe to make it
easy for everybody you could kind of
break out the 50 C's on a single page
and say here's an example of a 50c x
these are some of the Chri that fall
underneath it here and here's ones
here's the rest of them that don't
aren't allowed and here's the type of
things like the political action
committee right so maybe we have just a
one sheeter to understand which 5's are
eligible and which ones aren't eligible
be great can do that actually uh Val you
you all right well that'll be helpful so
we'll we'll have that for well look at
that as well see why commission before
yeah right so
okay so anyway
um and on the agenda I I said that we
should start the the conversation on the
number and location of charal gaming but
I think we've already kind of discussed
that and that'll be for another day that
we'll have a more more in-depth
discussion about that as well um um as a
commission so let's talk about the next
meeting
um uh my sense is that not everybody
wants Christmas is coming
up um and I know the the first week of
January is a tough one for the
legislators in the room because that's
when you're both going to be in session
dealing with all the retained
bills so I'm looking at maybe the second
the second week of
to so one one a session guys is that the
uh
33rd so that first week is going to be I
know in the Senate we're pushing all of
our hearings as fast as possible so I
think that second week again on Mondays
will be okay um because usually you know
we don't have a lot of that committee
activity on Mondays okay Mr chairman did
you say um in the last meeting that the
10th would be an option of
December
uh I got it in my book that we're going
to meet on the 10th at 10
o'clock
[Music]
um December 10th
10 December 10th is a Sunday
talking no December I mean if we were do
another meeting this month you know
pipes it be it'll be like the 18th which
would
Christmas January right to
January I didn't think there' be much
objection to
that
so well here we go now now now we're
we're going to be I mean the next six
months will be or five months anyway so
I'm thinking at January 8th Monday try
to do this on Mondays most of the work
is still in the middle of the week for
um I know with Co we it used to be in
the house side it was just Tuesday
Wednesdays and
Thursdays but now it's spread because
they've doubled up the rooms so they
have to schedule them uh all five days
for
hearings there won't be any session days
after the you know for a couple of weeks
anyway for probably a month so the first
week of January is out because there
there's there's plenty going on there
with all the retain Bills going to floor
various floors uh so January 8th can we
do January 8th all right at
10:00 January 8th January 8 10 10 now
I'm going to try to I'm going to talk to
your assistant actually too to see if we
can get this
room okay so we're g to try this room if
not this room I will I have to talk to
Aaron and we'll um we'll try to get one
of the rooms across the street just
little
few and then our our plan C is always
the
on all right I I think is there any
other
me
well why don't we do the 29th why don't
we do the
29th yeah 10
10 we'll try to we'll try to get yes
yeah I'm GNA walk over what
I'm all right so yes
John did we approve the minutes and I
missed it oh we didn't approve the
um we got a motion to approve anybody
seconding okay uh any
discussion okay all in favor minutes l i
oppos I'm going to abstain obain right
okay very good Min
all
than